here with the very latest from what we
can expect on Tuesday night he's at the
hammer Big Board of our very own bill
Hammer is there Bill good to see you on
this Friday night and uh we're going to
be watching a lot of races here's what I
contend tell me if you tell me if you
disagree with this by the time all the
votes are counted between Georgia this
I'm talking about the Senate races North
Carolina New Hampshire Pennsylvania Ohio
Wisconsin Arizona Nevada probably less
than a hundred thousand votes will will
determine the balance of power it could
in the Senate could very well I mean
it's kind of like where we were in 2020.
um you might be right about that Sean
I'm not quite sure you need me based on
that but what what I want to do for you
I need you uh in the audience tonight is
just kind of give you a primer about
what you should look for when you tune
in on Tuesday night so I'm going to take
you to the house the Senate and the
governor races not going to cover the
whole country Sean mostly Eastern time
zone areas okay so in the house you
could pretty much and we've been talking
about this for a while now in the state
of Virginia it closes at seven o'clock
they count pretty quickly a lot of
people in a very similar analysis on
this these are the three house districts
that seem to be the most highly
contested if Republicans are able to win
in Virginia too with Jen Higgins Higgins
rather down here in Norfolk then they're
off to they're off to a decent start on
the evening if they're able also to win
in Virginia seven and defeat Abigail
spamberger she's running for a third
term right here south of Washington D.C
then you're going to start asking
yourself how big is the wave if they're
able to also win in a Virginia 10 which
is just west of Fairfax here with hung
cow running for this seat then you're
going to be asking yourself how many
feet high is it all right but before we
go there Sean let's just say the
Democrats are able to hang on to maybe
two of these seats and if that's the
case we're going to be looking for other
areas on the east coast and Republicans
are playing in districts this year that
you would not expect just going to give
you a couple right here was the last
time Sean you talked about Rhode Island
this is the way Western half of Rhode
Island the Republicans really like their
candidate and uh and Fung the former
mayor of Cranston run against Seth
magaziner Alan Fung they like him I
think he's a likable guy he's running an
interesting campaign and if they're able
to score a trick there in Rhode Island
then that would be uh that would be
quite a swing the other thing of looking
at is Connecticut like was the last time
China talked about Connecticut when he
came to a Republican party well the
Western half here in Connecticut five
George Logan really good candidate
taking on Johanna Hayes just had to see
for a number of years they think they're
playing in that area as well so for the
seven o'clock closing time and the eight
o'clock closing time I would think about
the five races that I just mentioned
there to give you a sense of whether or
not Democrats are holding back
Republicans or they're not Republicans
are really getting the momentum the
other thing is down here in Florida
there's going to be a ton of news
Tuesday night on Florida I want to take
you forward one time here and show you
what what I what I think is important
this is congressional district 27. uh
Maria Salazar is the Republican she lost
in 18 she won in 2020. she's trying to
run re-election again she's running down
here in Miami okay a lot of Cuban
Americans a lot of Democrats she did it
in 2020 if she's able to ride this early
wave of voting the early vote in Florida
seems to just that Republicans are doing
really well so far and also you got the
big governor's race come on out here one
more time for me and then I'll take you
into the senate race here if she I'm
watching Salazar to see her margin from
2020. whether or not she's able to meet
at Sean or even surpass it that would be
an early indicator as well on the Senate
the obvious one that's right here it's
Pennsylvania it's fetterman and Oz could
go late into the night we may not even
know based on the mail-in ballots and
what time they process them and open
them and count them we may not even know
Tuesday night so Pennsylvania is a big
one I could talk about well I mean New
Hampshire is out there Ohio with JD
Vance but I I'd point you to George you
and think about this Warnock Walker race
you got to get to 50 percent the clear
and avoid a runoff come December 6.
that's going to be super hot that closes
at seven o'clock as well one more area
here the governor's races and there are
some some really good ones too I would
think about nine o'clock closing time in
New York you know as Lee zeldin really
contending as a republican in the state
of New York against Kathleen Hogle if he
is boy there's going to be some suspense
throughout the night not just for that
but a lot of these house races that
we've been tracking as well so keep an
eye on that George Pataki 2002 was the
last time New York had a republican
Governor I'd also keep an eye down here
on Georgia yet again he had two great
races does Brian Kemp get above 50
percent does he defeat Stacey Abrams for
the second time in four years that's
something we're watching also and come
back to Florida as we conclude this Sean
Ron DeSantis he's running a good
campaign coming off the hurricane Ian
run against Charlie Crist a former
Republican who was a republican as he
was governor in the State of Florida
watched the margin on the outcome of
this race they'll tell us a lot about
this election next Tuesday and it might
tell us a lot also about the next
election in 24. Sean back to you all
right Bill hemmer great analysis it's
the hammer board he I can't do it like
he can nobody can do it like he can have
a good one anyway bill hemmer you have a
great weekend hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else